sie sehen nun die Weihnachtsansprache
des Bundespräsidenten
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger ich
möchte Ihnen heute Abend von Kindern
erzählen die ich vor einigen Tagen
getroffen habe 50 Mädchen und Jungen die
mit ihren Müttern vor dem Krieg in der
Ukraine zu uns nach Deutschland geflohen
sind
sie haben ihre Heimat sie haben Ihr zu
Hause verloren viele von ihnen haben
Schreckliches erlebt sie sind so
verängstigt dass schon der Knall an der
zufallenden Tür sie zittern lässt
ich traf diese Kinder in Freiberg in
Sachsen wo sehen die Grundschule gehen
ihre Lehrerin erzählte wie oft sie die
Kinder trösten muss manchmal möchte ich
mit Weinen sagte sie aber ich kann nicht
denn ich muss ja stark bleiben
eine andere Lehrerin kam selbst erst den
Mai aus der Ukraine zu uns damals sprach
sie kein Wort Deutsch heute kann sie es
so gut dass sie ukrainische Kinder auf
Deutschland
wie schafft man das alles
die Schulleiterin sagte mir da waren so
viele die unsere Hilfe brauchten also
haben wir es einfach gemacht
ich erzähle Ihnen diese Geschichte nicht
nur weil ich dankbar bin für die
Mitmenschlichkeit und liebe die diese
Kinder erlebt haben sondern weil ich
heute abend allen danken will die sich
in diesem Jahr für andere eingesetzt
haben
ich weiß wie viel diese Krise ihnen
allen abverlangt dass viele sich
einschränken müssen
aber unsere Großherzigkeit im Umgang
miteinander
die kann uns niemand nehmen ein
freundliches Wort eine kleine Geste der
Aufmerksamkeit
Verständnis für andere Offenheit
gegenüber Fremden sie Selbstliebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger sie alle
die in unserem Land leben helfen mit das
Leben für andere ein wenig heller zu
machen
meine Frau und ich wünschen Ihnen ein
schönes Weihnachtsfest ein Weihnachten
an dem sie für einen Moment Abstand
gewinnen können zudem was sie in diesem
Jahr erschreckt geängstigt aufgewühlt
ein Weihnachten an dem sie sich freuen
können über Begegnungen das Zusammensein
mit der Familie über die Ruhe nach einem
anstrengenden Jahr
an Weihnachten feiern wir Christen die
Ankunft des Kindes das Hoffnung bringt
in eine düstere Gegenwart und auch viele
nicht Christen feiern mit und lassen
sich berühren von den Verheißungen der
Weihnachtsgeschichte Wärme und Schutz
Nähe und Eintracht
Zuversicht und Frieden
ja in diesem Jahr ist wohl unser
sehnlichster Wunsch das wieder Friede
herrscht der brutale russische Überfall
auf die Ukraine die Rückkehr des Krieges
nach Europa das Entsetzliche Leid der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer auch die
Furcht vor einer Ausweitung der Kämpfe
all das verstört und verängstigt viele
Menschen in unserem Land
auch die
Grundschulkinder aus Freiberg und ihre
Familien in der Ukraine wünschen sich
Frieden viel dringlicher noch als wir
aber dieser Friede ist noch nicht
greifbar und es muss ein gerechter
Friede sein der weder den Landraub
belohnt noch die Menschen in der Ukraine
der Willkür und Gewalt ihre Besatzer
überlässt
bis Friede einkehren kann ist es ein
Gebot der Menschlichkeit dass wir den
angegriffenen den bedrohten und
bedrückten beistehen auch damit setzen
wir im Dunkel des Unrechts ein Licht der
Hoffnung
Liebe Landsleute auch sie spüren die
Folgen dieses Krieges vor allem die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen aber sie tragen
die Lasten weil ihnen das Schicksal der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer nicht
gleichgültig ist weil ihnen ihr Kampf
für die Freiheit nicht egal ist weil sie
solidarisch und mitmenschlich sind
ja das sind raue Zeiten wir stehen im
Gegenwind und dennoch
gerade Weihnachten ist der richtige
Moment auf das zu schauen was uns
Zuversicht gibt und das gibt es die
Ukraine behauptet sich mit großen Mut
Europa steht zusammen und unser Land
wächst in der Herausforderung wieder
einmal über sich hinaus wir sind nicht
in Panik verfallen wir haben uns nicht
auseinandertreiben lassen unser
demokratischer Staat mildert die
härtesten Belastungen in den Unternehmen
arbeiten viele daran gestärkt aus der
Krise zu kommen und sie alle haben
mitgeholfen
wenn dieses Jahr ein gutes hatte dann
doch die Erfahrung gemeinsam kommen wir
durch diese Zeit und deshalb ist es mein
Weihnachtswunsch dass wir diese
Zuversicht mitnehmen ins neue Jahr dass
wir alle Stärken was uns verbindet
so sehr uns andere Sorgen augenblicklich
beschäftigen mögen auch der Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel hat nichts an
Dringlichkeit verloren er kann nicht
warten er braucht uns alle
ich wünsche mir dass die älteren auch
spät im Leben noch einmal bereit sind
sich zu verändern und dass die Jüngeren
sich engagieren dass sie kritisch sind
ohne der Sache des Klimaschutzes zu
schaden indem sie andere gegen sich
aufbringen wir brauchen doch beides den
Ehrgeiz der jungen und die Erfahrung der
alten denn wir alle haben doch einen
gemeinsames Ziel dass die Jüngeren nicht
die letzte Generation sind sondern die
erste Generation einer klimafreundlichen
Welt
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
wir waren in diesem Jahr zu so viel mehr
fähig als wir uns womöglich selbst
zugetraut hatten
wir haben beherzt gehandelt als unsere
Hilfe erforderlich war wir sind
füreinander eingestanden ich bin stolz
auf unser Land in dem so viele Menschen
anpacken nicht weil sie müssen
sondern weil sie Verantwortung Empfinden
für andere und für die Gemeinschaft was
uns im Kern ausmacht was uns immer stark
gemacht hat das hat Bestand wir sind
kreativ fleißig und solidarisch und
daraus können wir die Kraft und die
Hoffnung schöpfen für das neue Jahr
ich möchte ganz besonders all jenen
danken die auch heute und über die
Feiertage Arbeiten in den Krankenhäusern
und Altenheimen auf den Polizeiwachen
und bei den Feuerwehren überall dort wo
es im Dienst für andere keine Pause gibt
ich danke Ihnen sehr dafür
ihnen allen liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger frohe Weihnachten
sie sahen die Weihnachtsansprache des
Bundespräsidenten